all right guys bang-bang Travis is back
what's up man a little good sir how we
going we're great
this is a quarantine time now you got a
beard we're doing a remotely ready for
round two
yeah round one was quite popular don't
disappoint I don't know you let's start
with what you do and where you come from
yeah so I I run a crypto hedge fund
called a key guy asset management we
launched December 2018 we're primarily
focused on the liquid part of the crypto
market and to be honest with you these
days we mostly just trade a lot of
Bitcoin mostly I came from traditional
hedge fund investing background
specifically in the energy industries I
worked at a hedge fund called magnet our
capital for four and a half years doing
long short energy equities and non
controlled private equity in debt in the
energy space and then in the middle of
15 I went to point 72 in New York Steve
Cohen's hedge fund was a portfolio
manager there running a long short
equities book of energy and materials
equities a little bit of commodity a
little bit of options fell down the
crypto rabbit hole summer 17 not being a
tech guy not a tech investor not much of
a tech kind of guy and convince myself
that this is the most significant
technological innovation since the
internet the first time around and as
such was likely to be the most
significant investment opportunity of a
generation so I decided to start my own
investment firm when we launched in
December of 18 we had qualitative
research is a pretty big part of our
investment process and over the last
going on nine months now starting in
September of last year we evolved our
investment strategy into some
much more systematic models driven and
primarily quantitative so it's kind of
started off as something a little bit
more qualitative and now we trade
Bitcoin pretty systematically and so all
of a sudden we're going to talk about
today it's like all of the not even just
the crypto qualitative stuff but it's
good bits the really big picture macro
qualitative stuff that it's like wrapped
up around that and then there's there's
little 150 billion dollar Bitcoin you
know right in the middle of these you
know these really big things there's a
lot to talk about so when you made that
switch from qualitative to more
quantitative or systematic performance
went off the charts that's all we can
say I hope because we're LPS in hedge
fund which is important to get out of
the way but let's start with we're just
living in a crazy crazy world and I
think that you've used a number of
different frameworks to think through
this but one of them is kind of the
great accelerator so maybe let's just
start there with like what that means
and maybe you can explain a little bit
of like why it's important yeah so you
know I've been talking about doing this
for probably a month or so now and even
longer than that cuz I got I remember
kind of in in like mid to late March and
you're asking about doing an episode and
I honestly there were so much going on
that I didn't know what was going on I
was like I don't have a view on any of
this stuff yet because it's such a
tremendous amount of change it's going
on in real time right now and so I think
over the course of April some of these
things started you start getting more
clarity around some of the broad
directions that these various different
things might might take and if you think
you know maybe there's half a dozen or
so big factors
but you want to say what's gonna happen
in this factor and a factor that factor
and at the beginning you have such a
broad spectrum of outcomes that it's
like impossible to develop a base case
on on any of these things but then I
feel like over the last three or four
weeks it's I've at least been able to
start to develop these base cases and
then you can definitely change your mind
right as new information becomes
available but you can at least have
maybe like a base case to work off of
and then as new stuff comes about you
see whether or not you're right or not
right and so this concept I keep coming
back to is Corona as the great
accelerator and there's just on all of
these different fronts it seems like
Corona just accelerated things that were
already well on their way and you can
think about that in like a very like
micro personal level and you could say
oh man you know I was using post mates a
pretty good amount and it seemed like
this whole cloud kitchen thing was like
gonna get some legs to it okay you just
saw an incredible acceleration of that
trend that was already in place right
and you can think about it on on a
bigger picture you know work from home
right that was a trend that was ongoing
and then you can think about the really
really big stuff so like quantitative
easing mmt China a strong dollar
globalization versus D globalization
this generational divide and then those
are these big pieces I was talking about
and then it's like I think we're going
to talk a while before we actually start
talking about Bitcoin I think a Bitcoin
is just it's just the thing that's
sitting right in the middle of all that
and it feels like this idea of the great
accelerate really isn't just a financial
thing where you mentioned kind of the
idea of everything from food delivery
and cloud kitchen
but if you really go even further than
that work from home you look at you know
colleges and universities kind of the
questioning of like why are we paying so
much money if we can do the same thing
online and not have to pay for such a
kind of high touch experience if you
didn't even go even farther and start
talking about like okay well there was a
lot of talk about high valuations right
we saw we were kind of blow-up and now
all of a sudden there's a lot of
companies under pressure it just feels
like this is something I've used a turn
ology like the virus exposed the shams
of society so that's kind of the the
structural things that were there no one
really wanted to talk about them but
like BAM now they're there front and
center but I think what you're talking
about is more of the trends that are
that lay on top of that structure right
the things that the world was changing
already now people are being forced to
literally accelerate that change right
so you know friendly reminder because
it's easy to lose track of all these
things that have happened right so the
feds expanded their balance sheet by
just shy of three trillion dollars in
the last you're less than 90 days but
we're doing QE before anybody ever said
coronavirus the Fed cut rates three
times before anybody ever said
coronavirus the repo market blew out
five months before anybody said
coronavirus the Fed Funds flipped the
the overnight offer rate a year ago a
year ago that happened and so so these
these pieces that were that were in
place you know well before any of this
coronavirus stuff started happening and
specifically like this dollar shortage
situation which you've had you know a
few guests on that have talked about it
Brent Brent Johnson with this dollar
milkshake theory Jim Bianco I call these
guys the macro voices cohort see a guy
that air Townsend has all the time which
I've been listening to that podcast
religiously they've done a great job
luke Grauman goes in that bucket daniel
DiMartino booth goes in that bucket and
they all have you know a lot of
similarities around their their view
but they were talking about how dire
this dollar shortage situation was
before anybody ever said Khurana buyers
and then you can just look at the
magnitude and ferociousness with which
the Fed and the Treasury reacted when
this hit and you know that they knew how
tight everything was beforehand and and
and that's how you got a situation where
in the second week of March you had
capital markets seized up so much right
and it's real easy to think about this
if the VIX is going up at the same time
the gold is going down there's a year
you have a big problem in a financial
market and it's a Lehman esque type of
problem and I didn't think in the second
week of March that it looked like it
looked like an investment bank was going
to go down because the banks have you
know how to recapitalize like they're
not nearly same situations away but like
what about the risk parity fonts what
about all the all the really biggest
hedge funds that hadn't got involved in
the overnight lending market and the
repo was blown out the knock-on effects
of that right and so here comes the Fed
with yeah whatever was four trillion of
an essentially infinity actually no way
to characterize it was infinity because
they said but it wasn't just that we'll
do unlimited amounts of QED they were
also real acute they started getting the
turn that I like to use as exotic but
the feds started getting exotic with
that monetary policy stimulus and they
started doing things like like
announcing that they're gonna buy credit
ETFs and we're gonna do
Municipality stuff and you know we in
such a short amount of time you're
talking about talking about like 45 days
that all this stuff happened right and
you lose track of you know this this
term crossed the rubicon right we cross
the Rubicon so rapidly in terms of the
things that were acceptable or deemed
unacceptable previously that that now
we've already done them and nobody cares
oh and then we know then a ton of fiscal
stuff andrew yang yoga andrew yang was
running for the president united states
on a universal basic income with an mmt
under liar and people I mean people
thought this guy was crazy and then you
fast forward 90 days and now they're
doing exactly what he's talking about I
mean it's exactly what he's talking
about so I want to go back to the idea
of the dollar shortage first right which
is I think in the macro economic world
and people who manage money
professionally they really have a good
grasp of that would just spend kind of a
minute describing what that means in
layman's terms for people who aren't in
that seat and then we can get into kind
of some of the knock-on effects and why
that's put us in the position that we're
in today okay simplistically and again I
would say if you want to go deep go
digging all the macro voices guys
simplistically dollar shortage the
dollar is the world reserve currency
that means a lot of different things but
it means that countries around the world
want to transact in dollars dollar based
transactions
financial contracts liabilities
financial instruments you want to do
that in dollars because you feel good
about the stability of what that's going
to be that creates what is very broadly
now been called the euro dollar market
which is basically all of the dollar
denominated liabilities and financial
instruments that exists outside of the
United States and thus outside of the
direct purview of the Federal Reserve
and
when this dollar short situation was
which was had been again going on for a
year close to a year I mean I you know I
think the macro voices guys would
probably tell you it's been gone for
like five years if you want to go all
all the way back to you know when you
know I guess when in like I guess
foreign buyers of Treasuries stopped
becoming net like net purchasers of
Treasuries which I think was in fourteen
I know that was a big part of that kind
of dollar how that started
but you fast forward to today and you
have a big deal leveraging event a
market crash like we had in March and
the whole world was already scrambling
you know barely getting enough dollars
to satisfy these various different you
know contracts and financial instruments
and then there's this big race for
dollars and you can't it's just a vacuum
and the easiest way to think about how
big that vacuum was was that the fan in
the Treasury and the US government
announced north of seven trillion
dollars of monetary and fiscal stimulus
from you know over about a six week
period of time in kind of March April
and the dixie the dollar index which is
the the US dollar weighted against the
basket of international currencies the
Dixie was unchanged over that period of
time so seven trillion of stimulus again
you only did you did like two trillion
in the financial crisis over a really
big you know multi-year period of time
and we did seven trillion in you know
six weeks and nothing happened to the
dollar that's how sure the world was
dollars and so so the setup that that
puts in place is it now puts the United
States government in a position to
basically be shooting against dollar
weakness
with record levels of stimulus
unprecedented levels of stimulus I don't
know if you saw this statistic Goldman
put this out in their research about
three weeks ago the let me make sure I
get this
the disposable personal income in the
United States in 2020 Goldman predicts
to be zero point five percent higher
than in 2019 high basically flat let's
call it flat disposable income flat year
how is that possible that's possible
because of the magnitude of the fiscal
stimulus the United States is providing
right now for people in this in these
unprecedented times whether that's the
right thing to do or the wrong thing to
do is not what we're talking about right
now and it's almost like less
interesting actually does just identify
what they're doing and that's what
they're doing and as long as the dollar
is hanging in around here in my opinion
it's giving the Fed and the Treasury the
green light to keep doing more and keep
doing more and that's basically what
they're shooting against so the way that
I think about this right is you have a
dollar that is strong because it's
there's a shortage right it takes less
dollars to buy more of a good or service
and what you're basically saying is the
Fed and the Treasury are sitting here
saying wait a second I realize that we
have a strong dollar the way to drive
recovery is going to be to weaken the
dollar over time right if you talk to
somebody like a Dan tapper REO he would
say you have to systematically weaken
the dollar over time or you won't be
able to drive the actual recovery that
you need right and so what they're doing
is they start out with you know I call
it the water gun showing up in a combat
zone right they literally it was like a
couple hundred billion just didn't do
anything and then all of a sudden it was
they dropped a monetary stimulus bomb on
battlefield right and they literally
said hey we're gonna drop I think was
the 2 trillion dollars right which by
the way was a trillion-dollar stimulus
plan and over the span of like 72 hours
doubled in size before I got approved
right right yeah and that now all of a
sudden there wasn't wait a second we
still didn't put a dent in that and so
now you see you know the Democrats
having approved I think was in the house
three trillion dollars right and there's
just like hey how do we go bigger and
bigger and bigger and what they're
really trying to do is systematically
weaken the dollar by flooding the market
with as much currency as possible I
think that then leads to this world of
like okay so how are they doing that or
what are they doing with it
you've already mentioned that it start
out with easy stuff right let's go buy
Treasuries you know all that kind stuff
then they got it more exotic it
ultimately leads to the question of like
do we just get the ubi and mmt where you
basically have the politicians directing
where the money's going not the Federal
Reserve etc you know as we sit here
today how do you think through does that
happen or not and what's the
ramifications if it does happen yeah so
kind of the only difference between QE
and MMT is whether or not you're going
through the the machination of
pretending like you're going to pay it
back
in in QE the treasure crunch Treasuries
sells it to the Fed the Fed creates
money to buy the Treasuries and they use
a dealer right an intermediary bank they
use a dealer and in theory the dealer is
supposed to add some sort of one and
legally there's a there's a sort of like
legally I think it's a Federal Reserve
Act I guess or some offshoot of that so
legally they got to go through that and
then also in theory it's supposed to
like keep a market price on whether
that's going on right but it's like the
dealer that's not at all the weight so I
can just promise you that's just not at
all the way it's working right because
the dealer knows that the they're right
here to buy it off of buy from the
Treasury itself or the Fed make a little
spread nice little business and so I
like I think that when you when you look
at
going through the the match nations are
pretending like we're still doing QE but
with the Treasury right alongside the
Fed and then the only difference between
QE and MT is that okay we're not even
gonna borrow the money anymore
the we're just gonna create it literally
out of thin air and not even pretend
like we're doing this kind of paper IOU
type of thing and I don't there's not
really that much difference between that
and what we're doing right now there's
just not that much difference in
practicality so we're kind of already
there on MMT and again Becca's cross the
Rubicon kind of thing a lot of this
stuff you know it's tremendously hard to
walk back once you get it out there on
the monetary side it's really hard to
walk it back we've seen that like we've
seen this movie before we've seen them
try and walk back the monetary side we
saw the tightening and it ended up with
q4 18 dumpster fire for all risk assets
globally and you had Jay pal
December 17th 2018 talking about the Fed
was on autopilot and the market really
didn't like that autopilot right and
Trump didn't like that autopilot and
they did in january of nineteen their
massive Douglas capitulation again
reframing just how quickly we've come
here that all these pieces were in place
before we got here right because we're
just talking about January 19 when
January 2019 they did the DOS
capitulation and so so walking back the
monetary thing is going to be really
really hard to do walking back the
fiscal is going to be really really hard
to do and and finding the right kind of
give-and-take
in terms of the pace that you're trying
to pull back this fiscal support when
people can't find jobs is going to be
very very delicate and they are
definitely going to err on the side of
doing more not less that's just they are
so
what where does that put us with the
pace of quantitative easing you know a
lot about the pension liability problem
you and I talked about it some usko
talks about it a lot that again the
great accelerator that was a problem
before anybody ever said Corona and the
stock market move in March made that
from a you know a very very big problem
to this kind of gaping hole right if the
S&P 500 at 2000 the size of the pension
line and what that does commensurate to
other risk assets right so just use that
as a proxy for all risk assets what
happens the corporate debt what happens
in real estate doesn't work what we you
know pension liability problem you know
it's been a problem for over a decade
used to feel like it was a long way away
that problem used to feel like a long
way now of a sudden it's not it's not
feeling like it's such a long way away
and so here comes quantitative easing
we were twelve years on and do it and in
the United States we did PE and then
tried to do the Qt didn't work started
started QE again before anybody ever
said Corona and then what we know but we
think we know about the way QE works is
that it doesn't really cause inflation
it doesn't cause headline CPI inflation
it doesn't cause the way that the Fed
measures inflation for their 2%
inflation target right because you hit
one month since the financial crisis did
you get that right
we know that's that and it doesn't
really cause that much economic growth
causes a little bit but that was the
most tepid economic recovery and you
know in the history of the United States
since World War two that we had so it
doesn't really work that well for that
but what it does do is it makes asset
prices go up
and the Fed is dealing with it is an
organization full of people the same age
as the people that are having the
pension liability problem there it's
it's those are the same people and so
the Fed is willing and able and
incentivized to put the sp500 5,000
instead of 2,000 where that pension
liability problem becomes a much smaller
problem and they have a track record of
a willingness to do that and so the base
case that they're just gonna keep going
and keep going
ad nauseam got to worry about the Dixie
to a certain extent but you sure would
like it weaker than it is right now you
know you just did seven trillion and it
didn't do anything to the Dixie you can
look at what's happening with inflation
expectations right now right five year
forwards we're at 2% right before
anybody ever said Corona you dip down to
80 bits in March 5 your foreign
inflation and now you're you're hanging
out at one and a half percent one and a
half percent inflation
four five your four words and so I'm
also the opinion they don't want it to
happen too quickly because I think if uh
you know you talk a lot of different
people about about what's going on here
I'll talk to some really smart guys that
you and I both know that from very early
on said this corona thing is being
tremendously overblown and the magnitude
of the monetary and fiscal response that
that is happening in the face of this is
just going to completely juice risk
assets in a big big way and they're
gonna overshoot and the the motto
amongst that group is new high by 4th of
July they're talking about the S&P 500
in it you know getting back to the highs
of late Feb by 4th of July which is
would be a disconnect you're talking
about forty million unemployed S&P 500
at all-time highs that feels too soon to
me and I I would have thought before
Sunday night that they want it and I
actually think they got QB dialed in
well enough actually they've got QE plus
the messaging dialed in well enough that
they could I think they got a pretty
decent handle on on when to take the S&P
500 all time highs I thought they would
want to lay off of that honestly until
late September when people get ready to
vote so as my base case is something you
were gonna get new all-time highs
they're just going to use QE you just
it's just a lever you're just it's just
a lever but after listening to Jay
Powell on 60 minutes Sunday night that
was not a man that wanted to wait very
long before getting a new all-time high
in the S&P 500 and so you see these all
these different pieces that are kind of
starting to get put into place so when
you get that disconnect
rikes I agree with you that there's a
massive disconnect right now and I
continue to say that the the stock
market's not a representation of the
economy just representation of central
bank actions at this point right and
you're talking specifically about using
that QE as that lever
do you believe that they can stay
disconnected or do you have to have some
sort of matching whether that means the
stock price can go up it officially has
to fall back down to match economic
reality or you basically inflate it for
so long at the dislocated level that you
buy time for the economic data to
recover and kind of get up to meet the
expectation of those stock prices or
asset prices like I like how do you
solve the problem over the long run of
not having a dislocation I boil it down
to this is the way I simplistically
think about that I say it is a totally
reasonable base case to assume that that
disconnect will be meaningfully wider
than it's ever been ever before and he
just until you just kind of I don't know
use that I don't run an equity spun
right so it's like I don't maybe I don't
have to have it that dialed in right as
opposed to maybe some other people
that's just how I think about it is that
it's a great base case to just assume
that those things are going to get way
more disconnected than they ever have
before and they could stay disconnected
for an extended period of time and then
again when you know it's new information
becomes available you just keep watching
j-pal keep watching Stephen Nugent okay
Steve minuchin is doing the debit card
thing okay you made a joke about debit
cards with Trump if you've got that
going on and then you got Jay pal on 60
minutes okay so that's okay we'll put
that there we'll put that there and
that's you know you just you take it
kind of level level by level from that
perspective
so the one thing that we definitely
agree lockstep on is it's very hard to
walk back all of this stimulus right and
if you look at let's take the
unemployment benefits that the boost or
the beefing opera the extra $600 a week
we know for sure that there are many
people who are making more money on
unemployment than they were at their job
right you could argue that that's
because the unemployment kind of boost
was in a
Britt or you could actually argue that
that says more about people being not
paid enough before all this happened
right kind of two sides to that coin
Democrats want to extend it past July
right and there's talking about kind of
end of the year and their latest three
stimula three trillion dollar proposal
Republicans say we're not extending that
at all right and now you get this
political kind of battlefield over who's
gonna take it away right and who can
point who the finger at who because
we're in an election year so how much of
that like political really just
posturing right or peacocking if you
will
plays into the Federal Reserve decisions
understanding that Jay Powell in the
sixty minutes interview said Oh Congress
has oversight over us right right which
I thought was you know hysterical use it
to hear him but but how do you think
about the kind of the political layer
over all of these decisions that are
getting made in the economy yeah look I
think the first thing I'd say is I did
not come on here to talk about the
corona virus like don't ask me about
like it's like I try and understand like
everybody else but like it's been a
little annoying when you get like the
hedge fund guy to come on and try and
talk at the genealogy it's a little
you've seen a lot of that lately but I
think what's been really disappointing
to me has been how politicized the
response has become
and if you're paying attention you know
that to be the case and I just would
have hoped we could have done a little
bit better than that part of me you know
if you pay attention to what I talk
about you know I'm not a huge fan of
government in general and I think for a
multi-decade period of time we've had an
issue where the the best in this country
most of them have no desire to go into
politics and a lot of people that do
have a strong desire to go into politics
aren't the guys that you want in run
like making the decisions on how to run
the country and there's definitely
exceptions to that I really want to
point that out but broadly speaking a
lot of times the people that are most
attracted to the way the political
process is in the United States right
now are people that have these specific
personality situations that you know
would make them less ideal than than
some leaders that you could think off
the top your head man I wish that guy
was you know helping us around the
country right and you see that a lot of
differently seeing that in the state's
responses with the federal government
you're seeing that in kind of a number
of different layers but it seems like
the fighting over the magnitude of the
fiscal stimulus
honestly I think it's just posturing
because you're talking about somewhere
in between an unbelievable amount and a
completely unbelievable amount and if
the if the more Fisk fiscally
conservative side of people if they go
in their direction and it looks like
things aren't working out will
immediately do a lot more and and
everyone's very cute in on that and
again the main thing that they're kind
of kind of shooting against dollar here
where the dollar is and inflation and
you need inflation and we can't find it
we couldn't find it for the last twelve
years we haven't been able to find it
and coronavirus is a deeply deflationary
event but you have again the great
accelerator you had a number of other
really strong deflationary forces that
were already
he'd been in it forever technology right
technology is very deflation Airy been
going on for a long time
demographics deflationary everybody's
getting older deflationary it's the
yuppie yuppie to nerd ratio the ratio of
the the spenders to the savers and when
you get an Elton and elderly population
that's it that's a deflationary
fundamentally deflationary event and
we've got Japan as an example you have a
number front you in a bunch of different
countries in example one that I heard
recently that I had not thought of
before as a deflationary effect is
unprofitable companies so they're very
large companies that the market allows
them to issue equity in debt
continuously to fund businesses that
don't generate earnings or cash flow we
had a lot of those right we got a whole
lot of those because they have this kind
of top-line revenue growth or whatever
but your if you think about that you're
throwing capital into a hole that isn't
you know functionally producing sort of
GDP
growth right deflationary you have and
then here comes scrotal buyers deeply
deflationary and oil okay
oil you know does this incredible
pullback also deeply deflationary and so
so the United States is searching for
where to find inflation and so if you
use that as the base case backdrop
they're gonna keep doing more in terms
of monetary and fiscal stimulus and then
where else can we find inflation we can
find inflation envy globalization
and that brings us to this is what
shimoff was talking about and another
smart guys have been talking about this
okay so the corona this grown event sort
of pulled back the curtain on the fact
that there's supply chain issues number
of people have been talking about this
already there was a book written a
couple years ago China rx or something
like that the the book about how
vulnerable our prescription supply chain
was in America
whatever the stat is like 90 percent of
all blood pressure medication or so I
don't know I don't want to misquote it
but it's like real problem we saw that
come on you just recently last week you
saw the announcement of advanced
manufacturing facility for prescription
medication enrich min Virginia is where
that's being done a lot of people
talking about bringing in you know first
it's the kind of national security type
of supply chain so you bring back
pharmaceuticals you bring back PP&E
bring back microchips right whatever
that microchip company just announced
last week they're there now they brought
their manufacturing facility that
they're building back on on onshore and
then and then you can just get creeped
in terms of other supply chain things
especially you can get creep in terms of
other supply chain bringing it back from
from China back in the United States
when Larry Kudlow is talking about
paying for the costs that was a month
ago like oh I don't we just peel off and
the thing is is like before crossing the
Rubicon before all the numbers that we
started doing this go around to peel off
300 billion dollars to pay for US
manufacturers to bring manufacturing
facilities from China back on the united
states where are we gonna find 300
billion dollars
where we're gonna find that well now in
in the backdrop we have now we rip two
trillion on a thursday the other day
because what Kyle was worried about the
unemployment numbers like these are
incredible numbers that we're talking
about now so you
and definitely find 300 billion dollars
to bring the supply chain back from
China oh and by the way oh we get to
create a ton of jobs awesome oh and we
may be able to get that much much
desperately needed inflation that we
can't find
and then the real kicker real kicker is
that we did the fight communism pop so
the two things that are really
interesting to me the the problem you're
talking about in finding inflation right
I think the concern is there's a bucket
and when the buckets empty
that's a deflationary environment right
and we're trying to fill the bucket with
water and literally we started with an
eyedropper right is just drop drop drop
drop and then take a genius or a rocket
scientist look as I hey that's gonna
take a long time to fill that bucket up
or say hey you know what maybe we should
pour a little more water a little faster
and all of a sudden something like
coronavirus happening say hey we need
the bucket full right now and they take
literally a fire hose well the fear is
you don't fill the bucket it's
overflowing because you shot way too
much water and rather you shot too many
dollars into the system and so before we
get to the fighting communism in kind of
the whole China showdown do you worry
about overshooting in terms of the
monetary stimulus and eventually getting
that high level of inflation or even
just over 2% forget high level pump I
don't I don't worry about it they're
gonna do it there's no there's no point
in me worrying about what's gonna happen
because they're gonna do it and then
we're gonna find out what happens I mean
it they're gonna do it they're doing it
right now so I agree with you and I
actually think that there's a separation
this is the other thing that I've been
thinking about a lot recently there's a
separation between the inflation
actually happening and just the fear of
the inflation happening right so if you
go back to oh wait oh nine gold goes
down 30% you know some of the weight and
then they do start doing all this
printing and people just oh my god here
comes inflation they run into inflation
hedge assets those things explode right
gold hits all-time high and
eleven all my stuff inflation never
actually came right but it was the fear
of it that drove the inflation hedge
asset prices up here I think you get a
kind of a repeat there's the fear you
see people talking about it people will
definitely run it India's assets right
you even see Paul Tudor Jones talking
about it all those kind stuff but I
actually think that they're gonna do it
this time right and to your point does
it become a hayward targeting 2% and so
we hit two-and-a-half or three percent
or is this a will we way overshot and we
get into scary levels of inflation that
I think people looking around the room
saying hey is this thing gonna survive
look where do you think we end up if we
get the inflation yeah
so first you need to make sure we're
talking about headline CPI inflation and
US dollar terms so as soon as you step
outside of US dollar terms you know
people use this but turn the dollar
wrecking ball you heard people right
been describing what the dollar does to
emerging economies right either euros in
a lot of trouble I mean the euros I
don't know how much you pay attention to
the constitutional court in Germany and
like I mean it's in real trouble
Japanese yen it's in real trouble so now
you talking this goes back to these
macro voices cohort guys or your where
they're talking about oh you're gonna
flee the dollar as as they're doing so
much monetary fiscal stimulus you're
going to flee the dollar is the world
reserve currency into what and you know
another currency what currency are you
gonna go to everybody similar shape than
we are and so that's why there are also
gold bugs right
and I get that mm-hmm you know sometimes
I always have this nagging feeling in my
head about gold where when the entities
most incentivized to keep the price of
gold from drastically increasing
relative to the currency that they
control also hold 25% of the gold in my
head I'm just like
you know and it used to sound real
tinfoil hat until a couple of those guys
at JPMorgan went to jail on the precious
metals desk right now maybe anyways I
don't get into that but before you go on
it's not so tinfoil hat when you know
that they're willing to do certain
things because right now what you know
whichever side is right or wrong I don't
know all the details but literally
Venezuela is suing I think it's Britain
because they won't give them their gold
bisk everyone is admitting yes this is
Venezuela's gold but we're not gonna
give it to you and I get it the
sanctions it kind of all that kind of
stuff
but it's just you start to understand
that there's things that are happening
that everyone is a rational actor and
that sometimes leads to irrational
things happening in a market if you
don't understand why somebody's doing
something right and it feels like like
this is kind of Brent Johnson's theory
at Santiago right which is like we're in
bad shape
relative to everybody else we're
actually in great shape and so even
though we get kind of screwed if
everyone else gets screwed more than on
relative basis we win right which it's
pretty crazy
yeah you know I have this weird I've had
this theory again as a guy that has done
plenty of public railing on the Fed and
Treasury and all this kind of
ridiculousness it's a big part of why I
do what I do for a living
I've had this like crazy thought they're
like what if they were actually way
smarter than I'm giving them credit for
and they were setting up all of these
dollar denominated contracts and
financial instruments to exist and they
see that keep growing and keep growing
in the back of their head they go if
anything really bad ever happens the
whole world is gonna have to rush to try
and get dollars to satisfy these things
and it will give us the buffer that we
need to
on you know incredible amounts of
support for Americans
I don't know and we giving them a lot of
credit which is not generally been my
tendency but but at the same time at the
same time it's not out of the realm of
possibility
No right alright so as we see this all
happening let's talk about China here is
a man who's the president United States
who came in and he had to put it lightly
some very radical ideas compared to the
establishment this is everything from
the D globalization this is taking on
China directly in all the trade will
call it talks if you want befriending
dictators of enemies of the United
States and kind of playing up those
relationships to questioning very
long-term relationships that the United
States has both on the diplomatic side
but also things like the world the World
Health Organization the climate Accord
all these different things whenever
there is something very disruptive like
that it's obviously gonna be polarizing
so I don't want to get into kind of the
political polarization that's
well-documented but the one thing that
in some weird world we've backed into
many of those policies are now going to
be adopted but the impetus for them is
not going to be our president wants to
do this it's going to be the virus
forced us to do this right so the D
globalization now everyone wants to take
on China both sides of the aisle are
looking over there and saying whoa hold
on a second right and it may be for some
different reasons but ultimately we get
this showdown and so you know you know I
spent a year in Iraq a war that was
started over WMDs that weren't there
and there's a lot of people I think that
a question that whole narrative of what
you know 18 20 years later why are we
still at war in the Middle East this is
not a let's go invade you know the the
largest population country in the world
this is let's engage in an economic war
that 50-plus percent of our country
doesn't even understand
right and so let's just start at a high
level how you see us position today like
that economic battlefield if you will
like how is it positioned and then where
do we go yeah
the lots of unpack on China Trump ran
for president on make America great
again and like you said again back to
this the great accelerator he was
already making moves on China way before
anybody ever said Crona buyers
and you had the terra fours which were
you know a year ago alright that those
cranked up and they came to this like
pseudo deal that you knew that like the
pseudo deal was really just Chum was
like that's enough for my first term and
like I'm definitely coming back to these
guys in the second term and a lot of
this has been driven for Trump honest
has been driven by Steve Antin right
that is the most hawkish guy that's
closest to Trump and Steve Bannon was
out here the whole time with Kyle bass
and some of these other guys with the
level of hawkish nests it felt like it
was kind of halfway to Alex Jones right
especially it felt unpresidential in a
way because Obama was such a you know he
really was a globalist and he wanted
everybody to get along as a big get
along guy right and that felt the Obama
was incredibly presidential right it's
just I mean sometimes politics aside
sometimes I see Trump get on TV and you
really miss Oklahoma right regardless of
policy decisions but just like you know
Obama's a good guy right so so with the
so with the globalization Trump starts
wanting to walk that back and here comes
coronavirus I'm of the opinion that
you know it's it's becoming increasingly
apparent that the United States is gonna
hold China accountable for coronavirus
and there's gonna be a full uncovering
of the facts I have no doubt that the
intelligence agencies like let's be like
how how much digging do you think the
intelligence agencies have been doing
over the last couple months let's be
honest let's just frame it like that and
we don't have to answer the question
just frame the question they're gonna
answer for that and then you're just
starting to see the first things trickle
in right like what you said World Health
Organization okay a number of other
things and then here comes a supply
chain coming back and the the craziest
thing the experience for me personally
that's been crazy is that if you listen
to Steve band's podcast at all so I
haven't listened to Steve Mann and
before you tell us about this podcast
the one thing I will say about Steve and
Kyle so I did an episode with Kyle went
down to Texas and had launched and it
was fantastic incredibly intelligent guy
right obviously
I left and I said he really believes
what he's saying right there was there's
no doubt there was no kind of anything I
didn't know anything about Steve Bannon
before I went down there we did not talk
about Steve man and while I was there
afterwards I saw on real vision that
Kyle interviewed Steve Banta I watched
that and basically you could sum up my
understanding of Steve Bannon as
headline you know kind of coverage of
him right so kind of he was the the
right-wing crazy guy that the media
really caught took some shots at and
that was you know that's all I knew
about him didn't know anything after I
listened to him and Kyle talked in that
interview I said two things you can't
argue with this Steve Bannon is
incredibly intelligent Marv and Steve
Bannon
has a better pulse on the geopolitical
landscape they pretty much almost
anybody else I've heard talk about yeah
right and he may be wrong he may be
right he may be you know ill-advised in
one area he may be kind of you know
waving his hand in other areas whatever
but the dude is on top of a lot of stuff
and so I have not listened to the
podcast but I just want to put that out
there as I was very surprised when I
heard him talking on those two fronts
yeah so so the way the way that my china
view has been formed really over the
last probably five weeks or so at the
beginning of April I started listening
to Steve band's podcast the guy goes 2
hours a day like 6 days a week a lot of
content man and again it's like kind of
halfway to Alex Jones but I started
noticing that he was talking about
things that were that the United States
was going to do on the podcast and then
like 10 days later it would come true
like Trump would do it and you already
see some announcement you'd see some
move and he had talked about he took he
called the pulling pulling the funding
from the World Health Organization he
called that a month before it happened
and he was talking about it factually
and
and so that was the first thing and then
I think in the second week of April
I saw Bill Maher say that we need to
call this the China virus and that
there's not
we shouldn't be changing the
nomenclature whatever of how viruses are
named just to try and be not step on
anybody's toes in China okay this is not
Kyle bass saying this this is deeply
left right the champion of damara right
and then I started thinking about it and
you you start this is what I'm in at the
beginning of this conversation where you
see how all these things are
interconnected and you start thinking
about the inflation thing and then you
start thinking about how the hell we're
going to get we need jobs
we really really need jobs and then you
start thinking about the potential for
behind closed doors politicians on a
conservative side rapidly arriving at
the view that you know the CCP the
Chinese Communist Party is is being
treated as you know really a bad actor
and we're treating them them as a bad
actor because there's now this body of
evidence that shows that they're acting
as a bad actor towards us and it's not
kinetic war which was what we used to
call war like what you want to go do and
but now I'm talking about the economic
war and the information war and you're
increasingly seeing this this mounting
body of evidence that that is what's
going on and one of the main ways that I
realized that it was going to get
bipartisan support
after you think about inflation which
you need and the job creation which you
need
was one of the main reasons that that
progressives were having a hard time
getting on the this make America great
anti chip is because it feels xenophobic
right building a wall along the Mexico
Texas border feels very xenophobic and
progressives have definitely tried to
paint some of the situation's going on
with China in a in a xenophobic type of
manner and I understand that well what
you're able to do is this is not about
the Chinese people we love the Chinese
people this is not about Chinese
Americans we love Chinese Americans this
is about the Chinese Communist Party
we are fighting communism and there is
nothing more that Americans love than to
fight communism and when you can reframe
it like that is we actually want to free
the Chinese people from the communist
rule and then you start getting these
USSR look-alikes and that picture yeah
what what Democrats gonna what how do
you stand up to that
oh no I'm super super Pro China because
I don't like jobs for Americans in the
worst economic downturn in American
history when J unemployment rate is it
unprecedented levels oh no I don't want
to bring jobs back to America nobody's
gonna take that stance and now it
doesn't have to be about xenophobia and
again I'm not this is not my view this
is my observation of these pieces that
have been laying in place and the amount
of you know it was a little over a month
ago that I think got a kind of Kansas
realization and the amount of dominoes
that have started falling and this broad
direction is giving me pretty strong
confidence that the United States is
about to put the screws to China a bunch
of different ways and to a degree that I
think just a really short amount of time
ago would have thought is being
impossible and then
we're gonna see how strong the Chinese
economy really is like when the United
States really tries to start to to punch
back I think in you know against a lot
of different things that's been going on
so most of that punching back as we sit
here today looks economic right and
that's everything from weakening the
economy from the inside out pulling back
supply chains pulling back jobs right
all that kind of stuff also externally
weakening them that's through the
tariffs and all that kind of stuff do we
go from an economic war to a physical
war like dude does it creep out into
something that looks different than what
I think the path that you and I see
right now but can you happening
so I just take the view of experts some
of the experts that I've read and
listened to on this topic say that China
does not have interest in a physical war
the really sad part is that if you just
looked at history history would tell you
that with almost no exception you go to
physical war when things like this come
to a head
you know with very little exception I'm
there there is some hope that in 2020 we
can avoid that but it's it's scary but
but I have again heard from experts that
they you know make a career out of
following China the China does not want
that and that they think that over again
they have a tendency to think on you
know they think much much longer term
that I think US politics and things like
that are able to think on and they're
thinking over a decade over a decade
over a decade of experience or just
decades of going back and forth with
economic and information warfare that
eventually you know the u.s. just slides
into a sort of more subsidiary position
I just get the sense that over the next
handful of years the u.s. is gonna punch
back there yeah it was really
interesting Peters a han kind of a yes
global strategist keep him on I did oh
man listen he's so good and he basically
his whole theory for those that don't
know is he looks at demographics he
tries to understand how the world will
kind of evolve over time based on that
demographic information and he's of the
belief that within the next 10 years
there will not be a unified China right
he he believes that basically China is
on the precipice of at best breaking up
at worst blowing up right he's kind of I
think would be fair way to categorize it
and so
how does this affect the rest of the
world right you got the two superpowers
locked horns in kind of the middle of
the arena and they're gonna go at it
right and and it's kind of like a
prizefight in that they're both gonna
lay in punches to some degree the
question is gonna be who knocks who out
at the end is the rest of the world just
sitting in the stands watching or they
doing things that to help either side or
manipulate the situation in any way I
mean it feels like there's gonna be
major collateral damage from this all
right we know that the EU is the EU
economy is basically mostly Germany and
Germany his hitched its horse to the
china cart and they've been able to sort
of you know import growth from China
that is in a lot of ways buoyed the
entire European Union so I think there's
potential for major collateral damage in
the European Union is you know if you
know these suicides start going against
each other I don't have a base case
there it's more you know all these
different things these really big things
we've been talking about I really if you
can tell I just try and pick a general
direction as a base case and then you're
just waiting for new information and you
see if you're confirmed or denied and
what it looks like right now is like
okay it looks like the United States is
really gonna try and put the screws to
China and there's a good chance that
China's gonna do something to try and
put the screws back to them and we're
gonna go in that direction and then you
just watch is you know every time a new
you know every time Chinese stocks get
you've listed from the Nasdaq right like
you're seeing dude ban in a month ago he
was talking about at least three weeks
ago
banning on his podcast was telling you
this was gonna happen
that's what is made listening to his
podcast like such a
weird like just a weird experience
because of how accurately he's called a
lot of this stuff and it's not by
coincidence right it's not like the
guy's got a magic wall it's one of these
things if you if you want to predict the
future you know go build it right yeah
and that's what I was listening is he's
got the ear of the President and he's
basically saying this stuff cus what he
believes and he goes and he tells the
president hey you should do this right
and some percentage of those ideas you
know get through the filter and we'll
end up getting implemented I guess the
other part of this kind of superpower
you know showdown is in a world where
China wins that right and it happens
over you know a decade let's call it
does the US dollar lose the global
reserve currency status like is it is it
a battle where that is what is at stake
is the global reserve currency status
it's a great question you could put
yourself in the shoes of the leaders of
the Chinese Communist Party and they're
trying to play 50 year 100-year ball and
you could say man this US dollars of
world reserve currency is a huge pain in
our ass and it is a tremendous pain in
China's ass and if you saw in April when
the Fed extended those FX swap lines to
all the major central banks in the world
you didn't get a swap line PBOC did not
get a u.s. dollar FX swap line and then
just to sir we've very talked about
crypto so far we're going to get the
Bitcoin but it's just a circle back to
crypto here comes the US USD T prints
the tether prints all the u.s. the
majority of the tether printing has been
a backdoor FX swap line into China and
other parts of Asia that desperately
desperately need dollars and they'll
take them any way they can get it
they love tether they've been loving
tether for non crypto use cases I first
started hearing about that in April of
last year remittance payments
cross-border payments supply chain
logistics payments capital flight all
these different use cases and
and and so as as we kind of start to
squeeze China and we figure out the
different ways that we can put you know
yours puts the screws to them but in the
meantime you know incredible amounts of
money supply increase now look you you
listen to some of the macro voices
cohort guys like I think Luke Grauman
would say we got like 50 trillion of
room I think that I mean I've heard him
through you know I think these guys
throughout these insane numbers in terms
of the amount of room that you have I
don't have those guys have way more of
an expert on that than I do but I think
the thing the important thing to realize
is that
chickens are gonna eventually come home
to roost for the US dollar
and they're not gonna be baby boomers
problems they're gonna be our problems
that's gonna be your problem
that's gonna be my that's my problem
that's that's not my I love my mom I
love my parents that's not gonna be my
parents problem it's not Donald Trump's
problem it's not it's not Joe Biden's
problem it's not J piles problem it's
not it's it's not any of their problems
it's that's gonna be our problem to deal
with and so you're you're doing damage
to the strength of the US dollar to kick
the can further down the road and when
people talk about boom or sociopathy
that's exactly what they mean in terms
of you're putting him you're putting it
future generations you can just look at
there's a history to all this [ __ ] dude
there's hundreds and hundreds of years
of fiat currency history central banking
history there's history to all this
without exception when you do this Italy
it ends very poorly there is no
exception to that but it doesn't happen
right now we got ready to give and by
the time it does come to a head it's not
gonna be there problems can be our
problem so how are we gonna fix like
what's our generation gonna do to fix
that problem okay here comes a
non-sovereign for money really it's real
radical technology hadn't been around
very long to do it
boomers definitely don't like it I think
it doesn't make any sense at all
[Music]
but when you look at how we got here
in the way that we got here with the
monetary policy situation it's actually
a lot like how we got to the global
financial crisis on the micro level of
subprime how did subprime happen most
people everybody seemed to big short a
lot of people read the book if you read
the book then you know that a key factor
in how the subprime mortgage crisis
happened was because of a lack of
there's nobody checking anybody else
right and there was a lack of checks and
balances and the incentive structure was
all wrong right because everybody got to
punt the risk and yeah the guy making
the origination is it got the bonus and
then the bank didn't have to hold it
they could punt it and then the bank
that got it punted to him they
collateralizing there's somebody else
when there's Germany over there that's
there was not a system of accountability
well the same thing has happened over a
multi-decade period with what we've done
with with with the monetary policy of
the US dollar and that's part of this
get a bigger thing that I talk about a
lot called the trust revolution and as
we fast-forward through the rest of this
decade and I think we've touched on a
number of things that we're going to see
happen in the next decade real big
important massive things that are gonna
happen who knows what the outcome is
gonna be but as you move through the
2020s and you know we're probably at the
twenty thirty is the euro around they're
probably not honestly you know huge
changes that will have occurred and just
the world start looking at the damage
that's been done to the US dollar and
the fact that historically inevitably
there's a transition from one world
reserve currency to the next the last
time we had one of those was the British
Pound after World War one we got through
World War one pound was wracked people
use the dollar in the British Pound
together in between World War one and
World War two on the backside of World
War two British Pound was so racked we
did Bretton Woods here comes US dollar
I've been there ever since there's a
timeline to all of these what's the
chance is that as the US dollar
inevitably becomes so damaged that
people are really looking for where else
to go
that our generation not not our parents
generation our generation decides
I hope we should go with non-sovereign I
think we should go with something that's
governed by open source computer
software I mean look it I'll take it
even a step further not only is it our
generation at what point do other
countries just say look I'm not playing
this game right
I see the economic battle between the US
and China I see all this manipulation
going on I see the printing I just want
something that I know what's going on
right and I think that that perspective
applies to countries but to your point
also to an entire generation of people
who literally right now
the mean right which as we're learning
is the memes or the message the meme is
don't fight the Fed but money printer
Gober right and I was saying about this
the other day actually money printer
doesn't go burn it actually goes yeah I
mean but here's the thing right is when
you think about what they are doing
there's never been a generation that has
had the access to information and the
access to the people that we have today
so part of what I always joke about is a
magic show only works if you don't know
how the magic is done hmm but as soon as
somebody tells you how the magic trick
actually is carried out it's no longer
magic yeah right and what we're seeing
is they're revealing the magic trick
they're saying we we literally go into
an account and we edit the number right
if you all right second why do I pay you
taxes Yeah right why do you need my tax
money as revenue if you can just edit
your bank account doesn't make any sense
right and you start again that's a small
subset of people who start to think that
way then they see on you know the first
60 minutes of the crisis where literally
they're saying well we have infinite
money right we just we could print as
much meat okay there's a second about
cash bar yes then you get jpowel
right and you keep going to it and what
you rise is it goes from a very small
subset of the internet right this crypto
immunity but there's literally videos
floating around there's means I've
tweeted three or four of them where
people are taking jpowel and they're
putting him on videos of rappers
throwing money around right and and it's
a joke at first but the reason why it's
a funny joke is because there's truth in
every joke yeah and when you start to
see is the narrative changes and of
course there's some cut off I don't know
what the age cutoff is but some group of
people above a certain age or like you
young kids are idiots right you know
who's a Dave calling the other day said
young people the number one rule is
don't complain about your government
that's for old people to do right but
but the point being at some point that
mean is just accepted fact and when that
happens
trust ends up eroding away and people
start looking around the room this and
where's the most transparent thing yeah
right and I think that that's what we're
seeing happen the question is can you
get enough people to kind of tip over
and seek that out yeah actually get the
the tipping point actually occurred
right
again the great accelerator just in the
last 90 days like you've had an entirely
new swath of you know kind of almost
category of of investors that we're not
considering Bitcoin that look at the
magnitude of what we just did and are
really starting to consider it of the
person I really know that to be the case
right there's a few that obviously you
know Paul Tudor Jones is you know
probably you know the one that's being
talked about the most and that's great
and you know he's an investor letter you
know what he wrote was you know really
really good or I highly doubt he wrote
it with a guy you got to write it you
know they spent a lot of time on it like
a third of the whole thing was dedicated
to it and rent a croissants technologies
trading it again very different very
different type of investor and
I've been having some fun sort of like
daydreaming sessions imagining trying to
imagine how Renaissance technologies is
investing in Bitcoin
and like what are they because they're
not a market making firm there they're a
firm that like tries to take every
single financial instrument on the
planet is incredibly simplistic and
nobody really knows how they do it but
like again most successful hedge fund of
all time by a longshot they like take
thousands of financial instruments or
hundreds probably thousands and each one
is made up of like a tiny little slice
of a specific type of risk and each
instrument is like a combination of
different tiny little dashes of like a
thousand different types of risk and
then there's a relationship across all
those different types of risk across all
of those different financial instruments
and then you like try and find ones that
are you know cheap or expensive relative
to some other ones and you go along
those the cheap ones you go short the
expensive ones it's that kind of thing
again I could be completely wrong but I
mean broadly speaking there you know
it's something maybe something like that
so it's been fun to imagine like how do
they how do they code up Bitcoin like
when is like when is Bitcoin I mean they
didn't they didn't get into it and make
a change to their fun structure or their
regulatory documents just short the
thing into a hold of coal in the ground
they didn't it was more likely they did
something like a bitcoins cheap relative
to the fant the size of the Fed's
balance sheet
Xu no that's a very simplistic
relationship and then you just think
about that and then you and then insert
like another thousand different
financial instruments with different
sort of types of risk right and it's
just like it's been fun to think about
you know what do they think the
relationship of BTC is to gold or to ten
years or to the VIX or to Fang stocks or
to you know a lot of different things
like that but you are seeing you know
okay another example andreessen horowitz
right oversubscribed on a 515 million
million dollar fund you're seeing a lot
of different I'm sure you've noticed it
anecdotally how many people just hit you
up out of the blue right you're a little
dimmer you're like I'm the major figure
but in crypto for me I'm like for all my
friends and family and things like that
I'm just the guy that does a lot of
Bitcoin more than anybody else they know
and so you know when I get you know a
dozen text messages in the third week of
March about buying Bitcoin most of them
already bought and then you know we just
recently opened up our fun to take
outside investment again and the amount
of the interest that there's been in it
and you see a lot of these different
things where we covered so much ground
from a monetary and fiscal policy
perspective you know again I'm banging
this drum all the time big point is a
non-sovereign hard cap supply global
mutable decentralized digital store
value and it's an insurance policy
against monetary and fiscal policy or
responsibility from central banks and
governments globally been saying that
since the beginning of last year way
before any of this stuff happened now
you do seven trillion or monetary and
fiscal stimulus in less than 90 days and
people just start thinking about that a
lot more yeah well and I think part of
it is before it was a religious kind of
irrational type investment right very
very similar like a venture capital
investment so it's either gonna be worth
you know boatloads more than it is now
or is gonna be worth zero and say a lot
of people looked at it that way
now what people say is we'll hold on a
second forget what asset it is I know
what's happening on the economic side
because they're talking about our
television every day right and the
numbers are just mind-boggling what can
I do right and there's really only three
things you could do I guess four things
you could do right in the short term you
can hold dollars you can old gold you
can old landing an old Bitcoin right and
maybe there's some other you know kind
of crazy exotic things whatever but for
the most part those are four easy to
understand examples in the medium term
you probably can still hold dollars you
can old gold land and Bitcoin in the
long term you can't really hold dollars
Yeah right because it's gonna end up
getting devalued away so now you're back
to gold real estate Bitcoin and yes I'm
sure that there will be the inflation of
stock prices along the way
but you still have that dislocation
between the actual economic underlying
data and an asset price and so you know
Paul Tudor Jones wrote it I thought
really well where he said look the
fastest horse wins right and it's I
think all of these are gonna go up but
this one specifically and it reminded me
I gotta go back and get it
I wrote um this is in March I wrote a
piece ranking all of the assets over the
next two years and I gave stocks like an
eight out of ten right I gave oil like
uh it was like a five out of ten and I
said gold is gonna go over 2000 I think
is gonna end up from between two
thousand twenty-five hundred bucks but
it's a two out of ten because that's
really not that big of a move compared
to something like a Bitcoin where the
vault is gonna work in its favor right
you're gonna get this massive increase
in price and what shocked me was how
many like traditional Wall Street folks
reached out and they said wait a minute
you're telling me that the same drivers
of you know gold or real estate is gonna
be the driver a bit like explain that to
me more yeah you're already convinced
that those other two S's we're gonna do
well because of all the monetary
stimulus stuff right so I think that's
where you're gonna see the kind of
confidence built is that connection
between what drives this price compared
to that macro environment
another way to back into high conviction
around a Bitcoin along is going back to
the incentive structure for the Fed to
put the S&P 500 at five thousand again I
the way I was framed
willing able incentivize with a track
record of printing look at that pension
liability problem we need this thing at
five thousand and you think about that
as the backdrop
there's no way Bitcoin doesn't work if
that call is correct there's a you it's
highly unlikely that Bitcoin doesn't
work in a really really big way and
obviously from a percent return
perspective works massively but you know
that's a double so that's a double in
the S&P 500 from here alright a little a
little less than a double well if that
if that's the backdrop then I mean BTC
is gonna be fifty thousand plus it just
is that's it is and maybe there's a
chance that Satoshi moves as coins maybe
there's a chance that somebody does some
of the blockchain somebody steals all a
coin bit is some catastrophic
idiosyncratic type of risk and you got
to manage around those and that's why
there's active management but like
that backdrop it's really really
unlikely that Bitcoin doesn't work in a
big way there yeah yeah and I think we
were talking about is structurally
Bitcoin couldn't be better set up for
what we're seeing right and and it's
just interest rates drop you get
printing of money you've got a store
value asset that is based on an
artificially cap supply and you just had
the having right like that's the part
that that's so crazy to me is a lot of
the analysis I see right now talks about
Bitcoin in the macro environment and
they basically like as soon as protector
having isn't even here right it's like
that same part of the analysis when you
add in that part I continue to tell
people it's like gold in 2009 when
everyone should have been buying gold
before it went up almost two hundred
percent imagine it 50 percent of the
gold miners just shut off
mmm-hmm right and they just say hey look
have to half the gold supply that you
thought was coming on mines not coming
online now yeah it's been pretty severe
on Bitcoin that's been incredible to
watch over the last couple months is
people talk about antifragility a lot
throw that around a lot but the
juxtaposition of bitcoins antifragility
relative to how obviously fragile
traditional financial markets have
become and so so incredibly distorted
and specifically you think about Black
Thursday and that peak to trough Bitcoin
is down 50% in 24 hours really hate to
see that for your if you're gunning for
the world reserve currency being down 15
24 hours big problem right I get that
but the bounce the magnitude of the
bounce and how spot driven it's been and
also specifically around antifragility
this is this is a set up around Black
Thursday his leverage driven people
gotten real build up on the having
people were super super long on on the
potential swaps across all the platforms
tetherball rates were super high
contango was blown out I did a little
podcast with Nathaniel Whitmore with it
on February 14th at the end of it he
asked me what do you the biggest risk is
right now and what are you most worried
about
I said how levered this market is right
now it's very levered long as a month
before and
that was an untenable situation and last
time Bitcoin encountered a big untenable
situation was the BCH BSB Fork
a hash rate war thing in November 2018
and Bitcoin did it down 50 then two took
a couple weeks but it did it down 50
what happened after that was bit main
and Geon woo and Craig ride and Calvin
air and all the clown shows their role
in this ecosystem was diminished to the
point that it got a lot lot harder for
them to do something bad a Bitcoin and
don't you're wrong
down 50 right but it bounced all the way
back in this on the other leverage
situation very untenable you roll
through the Black Thursday down 50 in 24
hours but you shook it that was a
nuclear bomb event in terms of the
market structure for Bitcoin I can just
tell you that without getting into
detail it was just like and the entire
market structure changed and that entire
buying back I mean the vast majority of
the bounce f after Black Thursday was
very much a spot driven it was just not
derivatives led it was not leverage led
and it was mostly us spot in US retail
and the herd and we know a little bit
more about what the herd did now with a
little bit of hindsight right herds been
buying again Paul Tudor Jones don't have
any friends and and you get to where we
are today and you now have us in where
we're at right now
9k and but there's the foundation
underneath where we are at the price
level is much much more sound and don't
get me wrong
Asia is you know still the 800-pound
gorilla in the room but the balance from
from a bunch of different angles looks
to us to have been us-led and that's
real healthy and I think it's directly
in response to both retail investors
high net worth a guy buying $200 on
coinbase every from him to Paul Tudor
Jones everybody's looking at what's
going on monetary and fiscal policies
and they're going probably were taking a
little flyer on this this may be the
best heads on the face of the planet for
this thing and the market caps the size
of Costco so I should you know might be
worth doing
oh the part that's so funny to me is on
that 50 percent drop the coins that were
sold had all moved in the last like year
for the most part right over
generalization but basically if you had
held for you know more than a year at
that point they weren't selling and you
just saw the transfer from the weak
hands to the strong hands and the part
that I continue to go back to is we
could sit here and we could talk about
all the technical aspects of Bitcoin we
could talk about all the macro etc all
that stuff is important but at the end
of the day money is a belief system and
there is no group of people that
believes in a currency more than
bitcoiners believed in Bitcoin mmm that
just absolute hold forever
lock-in it's the greatest defensive moot
in the world right because nobody can do
anything to shake them right where is
the US dollars a lot of people who
believe but literally by the way when
people are writing about inflation
they're writing I'm questioning what's
going to happen in the future right
there's a shaking of confidence and it's
not I think it's gonna fail tomorrow
it's not I think it's gonna fail in five
years but it's this all of a sudden
doesn't look as strong as it did
yesterday right and I actually think
that when Bitcoin drops what you see is
the exact opposite of what you see in
other markets you see those convicted
people lean in more you rather run I
just go back to like that's really hard
to quantify it's really hard to explain
to somebody until they see it but when
you look at that that to me is the most
defendable thing for all Bitcoin and
it's the most bullish signal right in
all of this I don't know try and sum it
all up
those really big pieces that are
surrounding this thing and then you just
have this this non-sovereign form of
money sitting right in the middle of it
and I mean we didn't even get into
your Bitcoin in the middle of the China
versus the United States thing and
that's its own and and trying to bring
mining capacity back into the United
States and that is a trend and you know
stranded gas and renewables out in West
Texas and you know it's it's you know
the digital remember right the dcep and
that rolling out and it looks like the
United States is main gonna let Libre
kind of compete against the dcep I also
think that there's there's probably a
view internally in government that
nobody's gonna use the dcep because the
ante is about to put the screws to China
and and people just don't want to aren't
going to want to deal with the rememb II
and then maybe in time you can get Libre
to go compete on the continent of Africa
cuz that's the big the big I think
dcep on the continent of Africa
China one belt one road you know while
the United States States spent ten
trillion dollars in the sand dunes and
Middle East they spent ten trillion
dollars on infrastructure in Africa and
if you ask any kind of global macro
economist where the next 50 years of GDP
per capita growth in the world was going
to come from it's going to come from the
continent of Africa it is in the best
interest of sure the 96 national
security for I think the dcep did not
gain mass adoption on the continent of
Africa and they probably recognize that
it's a it's probably good idea to let
Libre Bill compete on that and you know
if you're in the Kannada you know I
don't want to speak for I've never been
to Africa actually they don't want to
put words in anybody's mouth but I would
guess that if you can choose between the
venmo that was loaded up with dollars
and a bin Mohd that floated up with DC
you know worth remember like you almost
being equal you probably picked a dollar
so it's gonna be you know big factory
but you ready for a wild prediction that
I think has a lot of possibilities
happening Libre is R&D for the digital
dollar yeah they're gonna let they're
gonna let Libre play it out fight them a
little bit let them know you can't do
whatever you want keep doing it come
give us an update do all this kind of
stuff at the eleventh hour all some
digital dollars gonna come out of
nowhere
mmm and my guess is right now it's
intellectually interesting to them right
we saw in one of the stimulus package
proposals let's give a digital dollar to
people to deliver the the stimulus
whatever they got taken out pretty
quickly but it's too sexy of an idea
they don't understand how it works they
don't understand how to do it they have
no clue the risks associated with their
anything but to say I helped put for the
digital dollar means you get reelected
right and so so intellectually
interesting
from from a politician standpoint
technologically we need it right for a
whole bunch of reasons and then from a
global power standpoint what you're
talking about its accessibility right
and I keep going back to look if you're
in Venezuela right now right or Zimbabwe
or wherever your currency has failed you
you want dollars right you want the
stability you want the Full Faith and
Credit of the United States government
behind you and you know all this guy
stuff you can't get the dollar and so if
all of a sudden there's a digital
currency that has a different monetary
policy and happens to be China's but all
you need is an internet connection now
all of a sudden China's currency is more
accessible to you than the US dollar is
and so you're just naturally by peak
path of least resistance you end up with
the Chinese currency or there's Bitcoin
and so that to me is interesting but I
don't believe that the US will let that
happen I think that they'll go ahead and
digitize the dollar and make it an even
playing field but ultimately where the
competition comes down to it's not on a
technology for cuz now everything's
digital it's at the monetary policy
level and I think that the one thing
that's gonna end up happening is the
internet is gonna break the Fed because
the Fed is dependent on at least fifty
percent of Americans not understanding
how money works yeah yeah and if the
internet you know basically teaches you
gives you access to the information you
say hey this is a game that's rigged
right it's rigged if I don't know the
rules so let me get out of this thing
and whether that's into stocks other
assets Bitcoin whatever I just think
that that education will be one of the
the biggest inflection points out of all
of us we're headed there before I let
you go two questions one I don't think
you'll answer but I'll try any price
predictions that people want to know
from you any timeline any price you
choose I know the last time we did this
I they'll bow into the wall actually
that's why they want you to do it again
[Laughter]
you
I prefer not to I guess Hank you know if
I got even money that a year from now
even money back a year from now we've
hit new all-time highs I mean I would
take even money yes all right that's
pretty conservative compared to most
people what they think is gonna happen
yeah I think
I get this sense that maybe the herds
not gonna let this thing run away from
them you may you may get into a period
of we may be in a lot of accumulation
over that period of time over the next
year and like how much you can disguise
that accumulation it probably depends
and it was certain potential for a lot
of macro stress but yeah I mean that's a
little that's maybe a little
conservative but you know like if you
told me new all-time highs by September
30th even money I take the under alright
what is the one signal or data point
that you wake up every day and look at
then he wouldn't expect you to look at
it probably it's probably uh without
getting into too much specifics it's the
because we've built a lot of models that
cover a lot of bases so the few things I
look like and to be honest me because
we've done a lot of this this modeling
work it's actually freed me up to spend
a lot more time thinking about and
researching the bigger picture it's
funny there we feel like it said we
talked about this big picture stuff the
whole time but like we run this fund on
a bunch of models that don't have
anything to do with the big picture so I
think the things that I still look at on
a stress-free basis are things that we
have not nailed down the model for yet
and I'd say without getting into
specifics broadly it's like putting
together piecing together a picture of
how much leverage is in the kind of
Bitcoin price discovery process at any
given moment and you know kind of
broadly how much you know if longs or
shorts are off sides relative to that
kind of price discovery actions happen
right now that's probably what I still
look at pretty regularly trying to
manually
yeah if people want to define me on the
internet where where you want to send
them Twitter is good Travis I'm just
we're playing KL ing and the fun
websites Ikki guy dot fund i ki GA i
don't like it i thought i'd get a
question for you sure
how's the what do you like like a
podcast guest expert now you time guess
it's like you already got one question
why why should i give you two but go
ahead I want to maybe use skills been
having a lot more of these conversations
I just haven't had a chance I've talked
to him recently asking this question on
the conversations with the more
institutional side of folks just over
the last two months how would you
characterize the state of that you know
kind of broadly has it changed is the
frequency picked up is the tone it
changed at all is it about the same
where people already interested in
January and they're the same amount and
like how do you care so there's
definitely I'll just say like fun
fundraising mechanism changes you know
if people had a focus on their own
portfolio not investing in new funds at
the moment give us a couple weeks like
all that take that aside I think it's a
lot of people who understand what's
going on they do this for you know
living to manage a lot of money and
they're asked the same questions that
the Paul Tudor Jones are asking right
how do i hedge this thing if it what
happened
if what I believe is going to happen
happens what assets are gonna perform
best and it's kind of this feeling of
like all right we're in the warm-ups for
Showtime when we're about to play the
NBA championship game you know it's it's
game seven more warm-ups so we got a
whole game ahead of us to play but like
though the four quarters get played over
the next 18 months later the next 24
months and
you know it's like any game right like
hey first quarter yeah there might be
some back and forth whatever but like
it's pretty chill compared to the fourth
quarter two minutes last yeah and so I
think that um that type of analogy of
like they feel why hey were getting
warmed up you know there's some
electricity in the stadium right people
are excited they know it's gonna be a
big game the questions just which team
wins and so I think you know that's both
the challenge and the opportunity of you
know I think I've told you this before
but I don't think ever so in podcast I'm
always shocked at how many people I talk
to in the institutional world that close
the door and say I own Bitcoin I said
what like and I'm not talking like you
know family office a you expect it there
I'm talking about like the CIO of public
pensions that are managed in like the
firemen's pension fund right and they're
like yeah I own Bitcoin I've owned it
for three years like I'm gonna believe
ur right I know all you guys and you're
sitting there you're like why you know I
can I believe the same thing that you
believe right and it's always funny
because then you look at their portfolio
and you say why isn't in the font why
have you not made certain moves and they
go well thing is that people think I
make the decisions around here right I
make the suggestions but ultimately you
know I got bosses right in terms of the
boards and things like that and so I
think that that is the been the biggest
challenge that is becoming an easier
conversation for a cio to have at the
board because Renaissance technology
Paul Tudor Jones JPMorgan Chase is now
banking coinbase in geminon yeah I get
all these little data points and each
one on its own doesn't really matter but
the totality of them gives you some
mitigation of career risk as how I would
put it and I think that that is probably
one of the more important developments
over the last you know six months or so
I feel like in the last couple months
because of what's going on with monetary
and fiscal stimulus I've heard more and
more people frame Bitcoin as Bitcoin has
to work here like it's if it doesn't
work here
you know maybe we should give up on it
because if doesn't work here it's just
it's not gonna work it's never gonna
work and then and then I think about
that the whole career risk thing and
then the generational thing that we
talked about earlier and you go no it
probably is gonna work now it's probably
working 20 it's probably working 21 22
it's gonna work in 32 oh and it's gonna
work in 2040 as well too as you just
slowly transition from the 70 year old
that still thinks this is magic Internet
money for drug dealers about drugs on
the internet and has never done the work
and it's just the decade-plus amount of
time that that rolls off and you know
maybe there's some chance that it's that
it's not Bitcoin because something
happened Bitcoin it ends up being asked
Jeeves and you know I don't want to piss
off the Maximus for this but I'm just
saying there's a you know whatever it
but like a non-sovereign form of money
and you know I think that bitcoin over
its history has had a tremendous ability
to get people to give up on it and cough
it up into the hands of people that
don't and that that's been an incredible
trade every single time without
exception so I'm always worried about
people being like oh it's got to work
it's been work now it's because they
make you sell everything and then right
after that it works the way talking
people about it is if you don't see a
material increase in price in the next
18 months what you will get is not
Bitcoin failed you will get people
revisiting what bitcoin is and why
bitcoin is important because one of the
strong narratives right now is the macro
mmm fireman and the macro environment is
here now and so it's almost like that is
a thesis that makes a lot of sense is
intuitive to a lot of people if it's
disproven again I'm with you Bitcoin
doesn't fail right but people go back to
the drawing board of like well what is
this thing right and I think that that's
a really
nuance because there are a lot of people
who say oh if it doesn't work in 18
months it's over my and I don't think
that it's over I think that that
narrative now comes into question my and
you got to kind of talk through okay
well if that didn't work in that time
period when you know what is the the
narrative that ends up proving to have a
higher degree of accuracy listen you
ain't got to ask me what I think you you
know where I stand I think I think a lot
of people you know we're getting to the
point now where it's not so much what do
I think about Bitcoin now a lot of the
conversations with the people who you
know in eighteen and in beginning of
nineteen in middle of nineteen we're
kind of should I buy some what is this
thing kind of all that early education
stuff now when I talk to those people
it's not do you have exposure it's how
much have you increased your exposure
right it's like they're on you know
stage two three four etc and I have a
buddy uh who who bought some Bitcoin and
when it dropped it basically dropped to
his cost basis and I talked to him after
did not talk to him on that day I called
him a couple days later and I business
like are you good right and he goes well
I guess I'm a Bitcoin or now cuz that
[ __ ] was scary right but it was just
this belief of like hey I wrote it out I
didn't panic right I you know whatever
and he almost felt like he had earned
the right now to enjoy whatever happens
next and I thought that was really
interesting opposite only benefits the
people who kind of had skin in the game
that day but I don't think that there's
that many people who held for example in
the november/december 50% drop I think a
lot of people got shaken out there this
woman actually think a lot of people
didn't get shaken out it was more of
kind of leverage in the Wall Street and
all that and so people kind of earn
their stripes now and now they feel like
hey you know if I didn't sell it then
like you know I can't ever sell it basic
so all right man I appreciate
doing this I think people will will
enjoy it I got tired of people tweeting
at me saying that we had to do a round -
you did not disappoint but we'll do it
again we'll do around three at some
point always a pleasure